Guten Abend, mein Name ist Aktaqa, ich bin hier zu ständigen Artisten für Sie.
Zuerst werde ich zu Ihrer Person ein Gefrägenstelle, da nachkommen wir gleich zu Ihrem Beuschverdn.
Wie heißen Sie?
Hallo, Guten Abend Frau Doktor.
Mein Name ist Frau Stefanie Graf.
Stefanie Graf, können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam kuscheln?
Stefanie, wie man es ausspricht, ST, AF, ANI, E, Stefanie.
Und der Nachname ist Graf, Gustav, Richard, Anton, Friedrich.
Danke schön. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56.
56.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich glaube 1,65 m war ich zuletzt.
65.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, das ist die Frage.
Ich war bis vor einigen Monaten ungefähr so bei 65 kg.
Aber wie Sie jetzt sehen, habe ich etwas zugenommen.
Ich glaube, jetzt bin ich bei 75 kg.
Sie haben uns so genannt.
Ich verstehe.
Und Frau Graf, was führt Sie so uns heute?
Frau Doktor, wie Sie sehen, ich habe einen ganz dicken Bau.
Ich passe ja nicht mehr in meine Hosen.
Die Beine sind dann ganz dick geworden.
Und ich bekomme ganz schwer Luft.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt zu Ihnen gekommen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beuschverde?
Ich hatte ungefähr vor 3, 4 Wochen angefangen.
Und ich bin zu niemanden schlechter geworden.
Seit 4 Wochen, Sie haben diese Beuschverde.
Ihr Bauch dicken und Beine dicken geworden.
Und Sie haben auch Atemnot.
Ja, jetzt in der letzten Zeit, 1 Woche ungefähr.
Und diese Atemnot seit 4 Wochen?
Nein, die Luft ist jetzt seit ungefähr 1 Woche erst.
Nachdem wir Bauch ganz groß geworden sind.
Haben Sie einige Schmerzen in einer Körperregion?
Zum Beispiel im Brust?
Nein, das nicht. Aber hier im Bauchbereich, da oben,
dann drückt es ein bisschen, weil der Bauch so ganz dick geworden ist.
Ich bekomme ein bisschen Schmuck.
Sie haben ein Drückgefühl im Bauch.
Ja, Sie sehen, ich sehe aus, als ob ich im 9. Monat schwanger bin.
Ganz dick ist der Bauch jetzt.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie Schmerzen im Bauch?
Nein, so dreckt Schmerz nicht nur einmal.
Ich verstehe.
Können Sie auftreten?
Wie meinen Sie?
An Ihrem Bein?
Also, laufen geht schon, aber es ist direkt.
Also, ich tu mir schwer beim Laufen.
Die ganzen Beine sind sehr gespannt und sind sehr geschwollen.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein, ich habe die dicken Beine.
Nein, Husten habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Wie meinen Sie mit anderen Beschwerden?
Also, ich fühle mich ganz schwer.
Die Beine sind ganz dick und das spannend natürlich.
Und dieses Spannungsgefühl,
gut manchmal weh.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Haben Sie Störfrost oder Nachtweiß?
Haben Sie nicht gesagt, dass Sie zu Genomen haben?
Nein.
Haben Sie zu Genomen?
Wie gesagt, die letzten vier Wochen.
Appetit war bisher nicht schlecht.
Ich würde sagen, eigentlich normal.
Wie viele Kilogramm haben Sie zu Genomen?
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht gewogen, aber ich denke so 4-5 kg wahrscheinlich.
Haben Sie 5 kg zu Genomen?
Ich vermute, dass ich sicher bin.
Obwohl Ihr Appetit schlecht ist?
Ja.
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Ja, wenn ich mich hinlege,
dann tue ich mich schwer beim Atmen,
aber Schlafen geht noch.
Aber im Sitzen ist es besser, da bekomme ich besser.
Können Sie viel lachen?
Ja, ich habe 2 Kisten.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Schlafen?
Ein oder 2?
Beides.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder bei im Wasselassen?
Mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, das ist so wie früher auch.
Ich habe nicht so viele Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang.
Ich habe vor einer Woche einen Hahnwechsinfekt gehabt.
Ich habe ein bisschen Brennen und Schmerzen beim Wasser lassen.
Aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Wann war das, bitte?
Vor einer Woche.
Mussten Sie in Nachts zur Toilette?
Manchmal, nicht so oft.
Wie wurde dieser Hahnwechsinfekt behandelt?
Mit Antibiotika?
Nein, ich habe da so pflanzliche,
zu Hause, die nicht mich.
Das reicht mir oft.
Ich habe keine Antibiotika gebraucht.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie eine allergische oder unverträgliche Begleitung?
Nein, das ist mir nicht bekannt.
Reagieren Sie gegen eine bestimmte medikamente allergische?
Ich glaube nicht.
Es gibt eine medikamente, das nennt sich nur weil die Medikamente nicht so.
Ich habe keine Medikamente, das nennt sich nur weil die Medikamente nicht so.
Das Vertrag.
Da bekomme ich immer so einen Hautausschlag.
Wann haben Sie diese Nuvalgin-Eingerungen?
Wann war das?
Das dauert für vielen Jahre,
als ich mir damals meinen Knie verletzt hatte.
Seitdem habe ich das nicht nochmal benutzt.
Nein.
Okay, verstehe.
Frau Graf, ich möchte Sie zu Ihrer Hochgeschichte einige Fragen stellen.
Beiden Sie an irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Als ich nehme Tabletten gegen den hohen Blutbuch,
hat mir meine Hausärztin aufgeschrieben.
Was nehmen Sie?
Jetzt muss ich mir kurz überlegen.
Das war, glaube ich, kann der Satan?
Kann der Satan?
Und wie viel stark?
Ich glaube, das waren acht Milligramm.
Und wie fühlst du dich?
Also eine am Morgen.
Und noch etwas?
Ja, ich habe noch ein zweites Medikament,
aber da fehlt mir die Name jetzt nicht ein.
Ist auch wieder ein Blutdruck.
Noch zwei Medikamente?
Ja.
Ich werde die Ihren Hausarzt fragen.
Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Frau Dr. Müller in der Bahnhofstraße.
Haben Sie noch irgendwelche Erkrankungen
außer diese Blutdruck?
Nein, sonst war alles ein bisschen stabil soweit.
Sie nehmen kann desertan acht Milligramm
und noch zwei Medikamente gegen Blutdruck.
Noch andere Medikamente?
Nehmen Sie ihn nicht an?
Nein.
Frau Gröw, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Sind Sie gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten Covid-19 geimpft?
Also bin regelmäßig beim Hausarzt
und meine Impfungen sind komplett.
Okay, ich verstehe, das ist gut.
Frau Gröw, rauchen Sie?
Ja, leider.
Wie viel Zigaretten täglich und seit wann?
Ich habe es deutlich reduziert.
Früher habe ich viel mehr geraucht.
Eine Schachtel am Tag
und jetzt wahrscheinlich so zehn Zigaretten am Tag.
Jetzt zehn Zigaretten, seit wann rauchen Sie zehn Zigaretten täglich?
Sie stellen mir jetzt Fragen.
Ich würde sagen, seit einem Jahr ungefähr.
Seit einem Jahr und davor eine Schachtel.
Wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Ewigkeiten, wahrscheinlich schon über 20 Jahre.
Über 20 Jahre.
Sie haben gute Entscheidungen mit Redutieren.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, manchmal ja.
Was trinken Sie und wie viel trinken Sie?
Ich trinke gerne ein Gläschen Wein.
Bei Feiern oder bestimmten Anlässen auch etwas mehr.
Was etwas mehr? Schnaps?
Ja, nach dem Schnaps Bier.
Trinken Sie Regen oder gelagent?
Ja, schon.
Ich trinke jeden Abend gerne mal.
Jeden Abend Wein?
Ein bisschen Wein.
Bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Proteinmäßig muss ich Sie fragen,
ob Sie irgendein Waffenkontakt mit Drogen haben.
Nein, ich habe nicht genommen.
Frau Graf, was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich arbeite im Büro, ich bin Sachbearbeiterin.
Ja.
Gibt es Schütteris in Ihrer Arbeit?
Immer, natürlich, aber es geht.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Ja, wir wohnen zusammen.
Was haben Sie in welcher Eta?
Stokwerk.
Was hat das mit dem heutigen Besuch zu tun?
Können Sie Treppen und Hinzusteigen?
Ja, das geht schon.
Ich habe die letzten Wochen etwas langsamer,
aber ich habe die Luftnoten und die Degas.
Das geht schon, aber ich kann es langsam.
Ich würde Ihre Familie fragen.
Wie ist Ihre Alternativen?
Meine Mutter lebt noch, mein Vater ist vor 2 Jahren verstorben.
Mein Lieblingsstil.
Er hat einen Herzinfarkt bekommen.
Wie alt war er?
Er war 72.
Ihre Mutter ist sehr gesund?
Ich meine 4 Alte.
Sie hat auch Bluthochdruck.
Noch ein paar andere Krankungen, aber das weiß ich nicht.
Sie ist sehr alt.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein.
Ich bin fertig.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ich bin extra zu Ihnen.
Mein Haushalt ist in Urlaub.
Ob Sie herausfinden, was das ist, das macht mir Sorgen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Ich weiß nicht, was es mit dem Bauch ist.
Ich wäre froh, wenn Sie mir beheblich sein könnten.
Keine Sorgen.
Ich will nur die
und lege einen wenigen Nösenzugang und nehme gleichzeitig
Blutab für Laboruntersuchungen.
Um herauszufinden, was sie genau haben, weitere
Untersuchungen sind erforderlich.
Was machen Sie da? Was wollen Sie da an weiteren
Untersuchungen vornehmen?
Ultraschall, werde ich Ultraschall veranlassen.
Okay.
Ihren Bauch und Ihren Beinen.
Duplex Sonografie heißt.
Okay.
Und gegebenenfalls kann eine City nötig wird.
Was ist eine City?
Computer Tomografie.
Ah, okay, alles klar.
Okay, das machen Sie alles noch heute?
Noch heute.
Jetzt würde ich Sie bitten, um die Wartezeit noch einmal
Kursplatz nehmen.
Okay, wunderbar.
Wir rufen Sie für die Untersuchungen auf in wenigen Minuten.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Geduld.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Mühe, Frau Doktor.
Dankeschön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch eine Frage?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstopfen?
Hab ich jetzt nicht bemerkt, nein.
Eine Frage.
Bitte?
Ja, Frau Graf, ist Ihnen angeschwollene Beinen oder Hautveranderung bemerkt?
Oder aufgefallen?
Nein, es ist nur sehr dick und es ist sehr spannend.
Es glänzt an manchen Stellen.
Aber was anderes habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Was ich bemerkt habe, wenn ich mir beim Bauch anschaue,
das sind viele, viele blaue Linien.
Ich glaube, das sind die Wenen.
Das schaut so richtig brav heraus, wie war Ritzen?
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, eine Pflanze benutzt wegen Haarinfektion.
Ja.
Wann haben Sie verwandt?
Ich habe gesagt, für eine Woche habe ich diesen Haarinfektion.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich habe noch eine andere Frage.
Bitte schön.
Ist Ihnen schwindel oder haben Sie Bebewusstlosigkeit oder Schwindel?
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt, nein.
Okay, bin ich da?
Ich.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass ich Haut oder Augen merkt,
ich verfahrt habe?
Augen? Nein.
Augen oder Augen?
Ich bin jetzt nicht aufgefallen, Sie können mal gucken.
Also da sehe ich jetzt keine Veränderung, nein.
Darf ich eine Frage?
Bitte schön.
Ich höre?
Ich höre.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Blut in Ihren Urin ist?
Nein, war alles okay? Nein.
Okay.
Danke.
Bitte schön.
Meteorismus.
Was ist Meteorismus?
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe einfach einen dicken Bauch.
Deswegen bin ich ja da, das müssen Sie jetzt wissen.
Ja.
Haben Sie die Unterträglichkeit,
irgendwann Lebensmittel?
Nein, also ich habe in Lebensmitteln keine Allergenien.
Ich kann alles essen und trinken bisher.
Okay, ich denke, ich habe eine Frage gestartet.
Können wir erst jetzt nicht beanfangen?
Oder wollen Sie Untersuchungsergebnisse vielleicht noch?
Nein, ich habe keine.
Der FSB haben wir keine.
Aber erst mal, ich möchte Senior eine Vorstellung machen werden.
Guten Abend.
Ich bin Senior Herr Aktaxer.
Hallo Frau Kollegen, Sie sind noch die neue Kollegen, glaube ich hier, ja?
Ja.
Ich bin Mikrobiologin.
Mikrobiologin, okay.
Herzlichen willkommen.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne eine Watiansin vorstellen.
Ja bitte.
Entschuldigung, by the way, ich bin Mikrobiologin,
ich bin Alsthetik in der Türkei,
ich war in der Türkei als Mikrobiologin.
Als, ja, ja, Sie sind, du bist nur, nur, nur,
erstens, erstens, und deswegen Mikrobiologie, Kardiologie und so weiter, nicht sagen.
Ja, okay.
Und Abi, beide FSB nur Nachname sprechen.
Frau nicht, ich bin Aktaxer, mein Name ist Aktaxer.
Frau Aktaxer.
Okay.
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne eine Patientin vorstellen, die ich gerade eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Ja bitte.
Frau Graf, 56 Jahre alt, 165 cm groß, 65 kg schwer.
Frau Graf, stellte sich bei uns vor aufgrund seit 4 Wochen bestehender
und Mitteil seit Schlimmer gewordener,
und begleitend hat sie über Dispul, seit 1 Wochen, seit 1 Wochen, und Ortopne.
Einschlafsstörung und Durchschlafsstörung.
Patient hat ungefähr 5 kg zugenommen.
Sie hatte, sie hatte nicht wegen.
Sie hat nicht gewogen.
Obwohl ihr Appetit, ihr Appetit schlecht ist.
Sie hat keine Probleme mit dem Sturgang.
Aber vor einer Woche hat sie ein harmwaxinfekt.
Und eine eine Planziehe mit der Nameniefterin.
Sie hat eine Allergie, eine Novalgienallergie,
die Sie mit exantem Oyzerin.
Sie hatte bisher keine Operationen.
Sie ist gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-19 geimpft.
Sie rauchte seit einem Jahr 10 Zigaretten täglich.
Und davor, sie hatte ein Schatter täglich 20 Jahre lang.
Und sie trinkte Alphohol jeden Abend Wein und Bifayern.
Die Patientin verneinte Drogenkonsum.
Sie ist Sahbearbeiterin als Beruf.
Sie hat gesagt, dass sie viel Stress im Arbeit hatte.
Sie ist verheiratet, wonne mit Iran-Ehrman hatte keine Kinder, habe keine Kinder.
Sie kann langsam Trepenstein und seine Begegnung verwendet werden.
Sie hat keine Gechwister.
Danke schön, Herr Kollege.
Ich möchte die Kollegen noch etwas sagen.
Ich habe eine 56-jährige Patientin mit zunehmender Düstpne, Bauchumfang und Schwellungen der Beine.
Sie hat sogar Anasarkar mit Gewichtszunahme.
Diese Beschwerden haben sie seit vier Wochen.
Obwohl sie weniger Appetit hat, nimmt sie wohl Angewicht zu.
Ihre Kleider passen ihr nicht mehr.
Sie hat eine Belastungstüßpne.
Das ist eine Krankung.
Danke schön.
Vielen Dank für die Vorstellung.
Was hat die Patientin für eine Diagnose?
Ein Herzinsuffizie.
Das kann sein, dass sie eine Herzinsuffizie hat.
Woran muss man noch denken?
Sie hat eine Diagnose.
Das stimmt immer.
Das stimmt regelmässig.
Unwahrscheinlich.
Aber sie hat eine Diagnose.
Sie trinkt reichlich Alkohol.
Das scheint eine Patientin zu sein,
der einen Alkohol-Abusus hat. Ist es jetzt besser? Ja. Also das ist ja wohl eine Patientin, die über
viele Jahre hinweg viel Alkohol trinkt. Also hat die Patientin einen Alkohol-Abusus. Woran muss man
dabei denken, wenn eine Patientin viel Alkohol getrunken hat? Vielleicht können die Kolleginnen
und Kolleginnen behäflich sein. Auch ein Problem mit der Leber. Zirose. Eine dekompensierte alkohol-
bedingte Leber-Zirose. Das heißt, der dicke Bauch ist wahrscheinlich ein Aszitis. Die Schwellungen
in den Beinen sind halt Ödeme und Ablagerungen, also Anasagra, wenn die Ödeme bis zu den Beinen
und zum Bauch hochgehen. Und das hat sich jetzt akut entwickelt. Also das ist, ich glaube, eher die
wahrscheinlichste Diagnose. Das ist sich hierbei um eine dekompensierte Leber-Zirose handelt.
Wie nennt man das mit diesen blauen Linien auf dem Bauch? Wie heißt das, wenn die Wänen bei einer
Leber-Zirose, ja sehr gut, da sind Umgehungskreisläufe von der Lebe bei einer portalen Hypertension.
Barikose, das spricht man dann eher bei erweiterten Wänen an den Beinen. Das kommt durch die Wänen-Schwäche.
Das ist etwas anderes als diese Wänen auf dem Bauch. Das sind diese Umgehungskreisläufe,
wenn ein Hochdruck über die Leber ist. Das heißt, wenn wir einen Ultraschall machen,
dann sieht man viel Wasser, eine sehr kleine Leber mit entsprechenden Veränderungen, mit
einem unregelmäßigen Oberfläche der Leber, vielleicht auch eine Milz für größer Ruch.
Was gibt es noch als Differenzialdiagnose? Wir haben eine Herzinsuffizienz, wir haben
eine Leber-Zirose, vielleicht eine maligene Erkrankung im Bauch, was vielleicht schon
eine Peritonealkarzinose denken, oder? Gleich hat sie ein Ovarial-Karzinom mit
einer Peritonealkarzinose. Und als Differenzialdiagnose kommen eine Akultenireninsuffizienz
wie leicht in Betrug. Das kann auch mal zu einer Wasseransammlung führen, aber das kommt nicht
oft zu einem Aszitis, aber okay, Differenzialdiagnose, warum nicht? Ein terminales Nierenversagen.
Okay, aber dann hätte sie wahrscheinlich auch kein Urin, wenig. Sehr gut, haben die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch Fragen? Also, ich glaube das war es. Also heute kam dieser Patientin,
der hat einen bekannten Alkohol-Abusus. Man muss bei Alkoholikern immer etwas kräftiger und genauer
nachbohren. Wenn man die Leute fragt, trinken sie Alkohol, ja, ja, so ein bisschen halt. Aber
wenn man genau nachfragt, wie viele Flaschen oder wie viele Gläser trinken sie dann ganz genau.
Und dann kommt, stellt mal fest, dass es nicht nur ein bisschen ist, sondern schon viel mehr. Also,
da hätten sie vielleicht nochmal genauer nachfragen müssen, wie viele Gläserwein trinken sie jeden
Abend. Ist es eine Flasche schon oder ist es nur ein kleines Gläschen? Und dann hätte sie sich
gesagt, ja, das sind schon zwei, drei Gläserwein. Das ist schon viel. Und dann wäre man wahrscheinlich
eher drauf gekommen auf diese Diagnose mit der Leberzimmose. Ich habe einen Italienischen
Patienten jetzt aus der Praxis. Der war im Sommer in Italien, davor war gar nichts. Der hat aber
jeden Abend fast eine Flasche Wein getrunken. Schöne italienische Rotwein. Ganz toll. Und da
war ich immer sehr stolz auf euch, trinke Wein und alles. Ich bruche kein Problem. Auch die
Leberwerte waren völlig in Ordnung. Dann ist er im Urlaub in Italien ganz akut mit genau diesen
Symptomen ins Krankenhaus gekommen. Und als er zurückkam, haben sie ihm so acht Liter Ascetes
herausgenommen, ist mit den Wasserausschwemmenden Medikamenten, mit Theoretik anbehandelt, der
hatte richtig Gewicht abgenommen. Die werden sehr mager. Und der Ascetes ist mehrfach punktiert worden.
Und da kamen jedes Mal vier bis fünf Liter. Und jetzt ist weiterhin so, die Punktierung
den Ascetes nach zwei Wochen läuft er wieder voll. Das sieht im Moment nicht so gut aus für den.
Und diese Patienten waren Leberzimmose? Wir haben sie heute, ja, sie hat eine Leberzimmose.
Sie wussten so von ihrem Alkoholabdosis. Wir haben sie heute ins Krankenhaus geschickt. Mal gucken,
was daraus jetzt wird. Sie hat eine Leberzimmose. Also bei ihr ist es auf jeden Fall diese alkoholbedingte
Leberzimmose, die jetzt dekompensiert ist. Wenn sich Ascetes ansammelt, wenn dann Ue demen sich
ansammelt, dann ist es eine Dekompensation. Ja super. Das war sehr gut Frau Doktor.
Dafür, dass es jetzt nur die erste Prüfung ist, Maru, du schaumst? Ja, sehr gut. Ich denke,
erste sehr gut. Auch noch als Mikrobiologin. Ja. Und in Deutschland ist es wichtig,
geboren nicht alter. Wie viel Alter. Das Geburtstatus, das haben wir vergessen.
Richtig. Und wenn man, ich bin verheiratet, sagt, müssen wir nicht zusammen oder
allein fragen. Nur, es kann schon sein, wir sind eine moderne Gesellschaft. Nein,
nicht. Geirrt und haipo oft sagt uns deswegen.
Warum braucht er nicht zu fragen? Okay. Und bei der FSB haben wir keine Seite.
Okay. Wunderbar. Hat mich sehr gefreut.